it's been quite a few years since
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
came to a close of the somewhat
optimistic introduction of Joseph
gordon-levitt as Robin ready to fill in
for Bruce Wayne as her protector of
Gotham City it was a perfect ending to
the series but some also perceived it as
a beginning of something new with
gordon-levitt seeming like just the kind
of guy to carry the franchise forward
into new territory you should use your
full name I like that name
Robin so why haven't we ever gotten a
Robin solo movie let's take a look at
why Joseph gordon-levitt will probably
never get to play the Boy Wonder again
DCE you divergent although we haven't
gotten to see any more of Christopher
Nolan's Batman films are since the Dark
Knight Rises the DC extended universe
are still forged on without Christian
Bale driving the Batmobile or any other
elements of Nolan's trilogy carrying
over for that matter it would be
sacrilege for the studio to continue the
Dark Knight's story without the
visionary writer directors involvement
and it would be a hard sell for fans too
so Nolan's trilogy exists in his own
isolated 3 film bubble Warner Brothers
new direction doesn't seem to be
touching it ultimately recasting any
characters that may have intersect with
it this means that while they're rolling
full steam ahead with an interconnected
universe of superheroes who all share a
singular continuity Joseph
gordon-levitt's Robin is probably now
considered to be just as untouchable as
anything else Nolan came up with making
matters worse and the current DC
extended universe
Robin has already gone as shown in dawn
of Justice when Bruce Wayne passes by a
display case containing Robins old suit
the whole idea was that there had been
loss and there had been sacrifice so
even if Nolan did eventually give us
blessing to borrow his version of Robin
well they've written themselves into a
corner with that already still Batman
has no shortage of Robins floating
around but there are more problems than
just one Robin being underground whoa
there are three other Robins oh there
have been more than that hum golly Oh
John Batman does go through a sidekick
or two Nightwing's next instead of
bringing Robin back to life it looks
like Warner Brothers is eyeing the
sidekicks other alter ego to get his day
in the Sun in the comics
Nightwing is Robin's new identity after
he realized as being Robin is lame and
he ditches Batman to pursue his own soul
Adventures under the new mantle this is
my gig if I needed you out of call this
decision by Warner Brothers to move
forward on a Nightwing movie and
arguably without any Joseph
gordon-levitt Robin plants it's
important to maintain the DCE use
continuity and to build a new status for
Nightwing a character with far more
alias potential than Robin unless Warner
Brothers breaks its tradition of
refusing to recycle any of Nolan's old
cast members and retrofit a new
character with the history of an older
one chances are Joseph gordon-levitt
won't be the go to lead up this movie
Eva
best left alone irrespective of the
other reasons Joseph gordon-levitt's
hypothetical Robin film will never take
flight there's also the problem of
Robins and popularity as a character in
general evidence for this is pretty
blatant as a single time audience
members had a say regarding his
inclusion in a Batman story they chose
to put an end to him yes really
in 1988 DC Comics asked to readers if
Jason Todd who domed Robin's green and
red spandex at the time should be taken
out or spared and fans voted to end his
life since then no one's really been
seen clamoring for more Robin centric
fiction and it probably doesn't help
that of the many Batman films in the
Caped Crusader's cinematic history the
ones that prominently feature Robin are
widely considered the worst of the bunch
Robin in Batman and I'm sick of me that
probably means the character isn't
viable as a standalone centerpiece for
any movie let alone one with a
significant budget actor a parfait the
real death knell for hopes of a beloved
actor playing a role you'd really like
to see them in happens when they
personally come out and say it would be
an inappropriate idea worsen gap we've
seen people backpedal and comments about
disinterest before but to call a Robin
spin-off inappropriate and say that the
Dark Knight trilogy ended exactly where
it should well it's hard to walk but
those kind of comments if a Robin movie
ever happens will be introduced to a
brand new boy in tights
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
you